cette famille d'américains ne ressemble
à aucune autre puisqu'elle est composée
de 4 par an ayyash jeune alicia et tyler
ont fait le choix il ya trois ans de
former une relation poli amoureuse c'est
un bordel au delà des parties de jambes
en l'air qu'ils ont eu ensemble les deux
groupes ont décidé de s'installer dans
la même maison et de fonder une vraie
famille au début je partageais de nuit
avec sean et une avec tyler mais
maintenant c'est non hiérarchique nous
sommes tous sur la même page et cela
fonctionne mieux en si le problème quand
on partage tout c'est qu'on ne sait plus
forcément avec qui on l'a partagée est
quant à elle ici à tomber enceinte
difficile de savoir qui est le père nous
ne savons pas nous ne nions pas savoir
nous avons dit que nous serions tous les
parents de chacun devant des enfants par
conséquent deux papas et de mamans et
surtout deux fois plus de cadeaux à noël
[Musique]
alors le point bourse et conclure yavo
c'est une orientation dans laquelle les
partenaires sont en relation amoureuse
avec plus d'une personne avec le
consentement de le consentement de
toutes les personnes concernées vous
mathieu
allard moi je crois plus en plus je
pense que le machin après je pense que
la banque plate 2 c'est quelque chose
qui est désuet main entre non non non je
suis pas d'accord on se rend compte que
ça un jeu pas d'accord voulant parler
mais je veux d'abord cette chose qui
fonctionne mal qui fonctionne peu c'est
soit la frustration soit un divorce j'ai
pas terminée je pense que maintenant qui
pourrait trahir un petit peu parce qu'au
bâton et un carcan on pensait qu'un
couple s'était de personnes à mariage
nanin en ab on a en la prédication moi
je défends pas j'aurais bien fait le mec
aujourd'hui
je peux dire que j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui maintenant vivent à 3 n'ont jamais
nourri aide j'aurais jamais dit ça ya
dix ans aujourd'hui je pense que je
pense que vivre à trois avec un
troisième gras sorte quoi tu me demandes
mais c'est pas une question de
soi je pense que vivra trois
effectivement aujourd'hui encore une
fois l'amour c'est quoi ces agnel est ce
que fait la voiture impoli amour
c'est ça je me lâche en train de
calculer je me dis que j'ai tout laissé
toutes les filles prennent deux mecs
ça va être dur non mais moi ça fin ça
m'écoeure ça ça mais ça m'écoeure je
suis désolé je suis la vieille je ne
veux pas de ce côté là contre les
enfants cc c'est pas salé des enfants
c'est hyper v cela me disant
savoir qu'ils étaient parties ces femmes
qui est effectivement papa ou de maman
là bas c'est là par la terre dit paul
sont libres tout le monde sait ce qu'il
veut avec moi je ne veux pas de ce monde
là je n'aime pas ce monde gilbert était
obligé de vivre sa
[Rires]
connaissance c'est trop d'ennuis déjà
deux c'est compliqué mais vous imaginez
à 4 c1 c'est monstrueux c'est pas
possible vos chocolats et moi dans ma
famille j'ai eu des trucs comme ça il ya
eu d d d d inversion des sorts qui ont
porté l'enfant
pour la soeur c'est à dire qu'il y avait
une soeur qui était stérile elle a
couché avec leurs maris xi arrivé à la
porte elle si si c'est du côté de feu
mon papa est donc elle a porté l'enfant
pour sa soeur en couchant avec le mari
de sa soeur
nancy 6 à 6 cm mais j'ai dit non c'est
pas dangereux en revanche je ne dirais
pas non non rien à voir le mari de sa
soeur n'ont pas son frère avait pas
d'accord en fait il a le vin le mari de
la soeur de gilles d'accord à ken la
foule
la c6 unique mais voilà ils savent très
bien passé ce soir j'ai rien compris à
la vie une soeur n'ont fait math soeur
du côté de mon père il y avait deux
soeurs de ton père le jeune femme un peu
plus lointain 2 jeune femme et ses deux
jeunes femmes il y en a une qui était
stérile et bien sa soeur a couché avec
son mari away au portail après lui a
fait don de l'enfant mais elle cause
avant leur temps la femme accord j'ai
trouvé que c'est un beau geste d'amour
ouais ouais un peu relou quand même bref
c'est vrai un parent ou le monde s'aime
comme daniel owassa peu à
celle où
ils peuvent être super heureux les
barbecues ya du monde et même si tu
devais attend et battu à lyon il ya
peut-être un petit peu trop tard
pour acheter une baraque c'est pratique
du deux roues et d'emprunter 13000 temps
26 ans mais dit pas les démons n'évolue
pas moi j'ai voulu qu'à moi j'évolue pas
je suis désolé moi ma meuf 600 euros
c'est pas mal c'est ma main ce principe
c'est encore une fois l'amour aveugle
c'est la personne qui se mettent
d'accord sur un contrat pas du tout ces
deux personnes qui s'aiment ils s'aiment
et ben oui mais cris se mettre d'accord
à l'étude pour tromper pas tous trompés
de vivre a pas du tout de faire des
plans à trois de machin si les deux sont
d'accord ça marche c'est pas du tout ça
m'a tellement ça va du tout on taxait
brahma 9 à l'écrit même un sms un mec
c'est fini
ma castaldi ah oui
sms et trompe elana regretter votre
abouba elle a le droit de voter votre
s'avoue pas conduit à quoi je vais
conduire
lui conduit maison
real a un petit truc
introduit dans la maison
c'est nicolas alors moi non mais moi je
vous avez raison syrie dresse maintenant
elle sera codée souvenirs aux moi même
un télégramme à ma meuf c'est ouais
c'était daniel ma meuf passe par
sms s'est trompé je suis désolé nous
avons fermé pendu à l'aide de l'autre
côté aussi dont elle vérifie aussi vos
sms alors moi je peux vous dire abbas a
regardé tout à l'heure
alors je peux mais à témoin bien je peux
lui laissé mon téléphone je peux oublier
au téléphone ouais c'est pas en angoisse
a pas du tout pas du tout il est 9
mémoire et vider les ananas surtout
genton non moi je suis scandalisé par le
polyamour moi l'amour c'est évidemment à
deux et je sais que c'est
toi toi tais toi
hanouna
c'est d'accord avec vous j'ai pas trouvé
jeudi un accord avec vous un faux cul je
suis d'accord
t'as un faux cul mais moi
personnellement c'est vrai que je suis
pas un mais deux camps se livrent à fond
celui là mais c'est vrai et en plus vous
êtes quand même enfin tu es un gros
hypocrites ouais parce qu'en fait ça
rassure les mecs de dire ouais moi je
suis pas pour le polyamour moi j'aime
l'amour et tout ça et après vous pouvez
aussi trompé vider des relations adultes
heureusement ça va tromper non pas toi
en général
le groupe moli amoureux c'est quand même
une belle plante pour pouvoir tromper
non mais pas celle à leur démarche et en
l'occurrence elle est très égoïste parce
qu'en fait ils voient le bonheur qu'à
travers leur plaisir personnel et ils ne
pensent même pas aux enfants non mélange
tout mais non ne dit même pas aux
enfants qu'ils aient leurs pairs et non
franchement c'est ne pas fondre les
enfants seront heureux et 17 ans et
son père
peut-être que le jour où l'enfant
demandera ils feront des tests de
paternité et dire on bat on perd en fait
ce soir et avec sa tombe déjà vous aider
vous de vieux trompent et trompent et
déjà appartement djaout il dit à l'autre
c'est déjà pas trompé tu ne le trompe
pas parce que tu es ici on attend donc
que tu vas quand même pas venir me voir
me dérange qui avec jean marc
et marie tu te jure fidélité
la fidélité je pense qu'effectivement
quand on vit 4 30 40 50 ans avec
quelqu'un qui est important c'est la
qualité du quotidien le reste après
c'est cette technique mais bien sûr moi
demain demain au bout de cinq ans
j'apprends que mon copain il m'a trompé
une fois tu vas te dis pas d'avoir une
vie parallèle il m'a trompé une fois so
what
simone de beauvoir les amours
contingentes et simone de beauvoir oui
il appelait les amours essentiels et les
amours contingentes et donc après que
j'avais ce que des risques dit mathieu
en fait et théorisé tous ceux qui sont
pas d'accord avec moi pardon on le voit
ici il n'y a pas un qui a dépassé 10 ans
labrecque a dépassé
on assure moi j'ai dépassé 10 ans enfin
maintenant célibataire vois ça oui mais
tarf et à vie par tout à fait l'avis
refaite à vire fait à villeneuve fois
pas tout puisque la durée depuis le
début g lausanne c'est la télé qui fait
ça si c'est la télé qui vous trouvez pas
quelqu'un qui fait de la télé qui reste
avec sa femme depuis dix ans la télé
c'est un témoignage
c'est la télé qui fait ça va ça va il a
pas le temps